[Music]
what a what a what a what an
absolute what a l what a what a what an
[Music]
absolute a what a lad well when I ask
people in this part of the world who is
the biggest lad to ever play for the
Crusaders many will give me the name of
today's guest here's a true Southland
canbury and crusader Legend who went on
to two rugby World Cups with the All
Blacks and of course did something not
many get to do and won it in 2011 he
also played over in France with too and
in Scotland with Glasgow he is one of
the game's greatest Lads there is it is
of course the great man Corey Flynn
welcome mate gez mate it's uh yeah
pleasure to be on a longtime listener so
uh yeah we'll see how this goes yeah
mate I've been trying to get you on for
a we while now I've been um wanting to
do this one in person but obviously
everyone I do speak to um speak so
highly of you um especially around this
part of the world so um you've left a
real um I guess Legacy here in the
Crusaders region yeah it's I mean this
was a really special part of my life um
coming from inago just a a young fell
and then drafted up in 202 and then I
Was Here For What was you know left in
2014 so massive part of my life and um
pretty much gave me everything that I've
got sort of leading forward M and I
guess a lot of people wondering what
what do you do now like what does what
does Cory Flynn do now yeah so um into
in the construction industry um left
rugby without a without basically a plan
and you know much like many footballers
um yeah went through mad old
apprentiship with a with one of my best
mates he um he was hiring and he said
look you know I'm taking on a uh an
apprentice so I'd like an ADD cuz I pay
you on a Wednesday and I know you're
going to shop up Thursday Friday if you
don't shop up Monday then you've pretty
much been on the booze with me on Sunday
so so I did that for I did that for
about six years loved it um and then I
was still trying to play a little bit of
footy this year with the nomads still
playing yeah yeah oh you know it's um
you you still love it yeah but and the
nomads boys they um they don't take too
too kindly to the training aspect but
still love playing you know so and it is
it's just a it's just a way of getting
together and having a beer and catch up
and not worrying about uh too many of
the stresses of life and doing something
that you do naturally anyway yeah so so
I was doing that I'm blew my shoulder in
the first
[Music]
game probably probably due to the fact
that there's no training um but yes I
saw the saw the surgeon and he's just he
just basically told me to grow up and
said you know you got to you got to
you're 42 years old old you got a
shoulder of a 65y old so it's time to
give
up that is decent effort though like um
to still be out there playing is that
like did you find that transition really
hard going from playing to um out of
that professional environment is that
why you felt like you just wanted to
keep going yeah not not so much the
transition but it's what you get with
the rugby so I don't miss the trainings
the meetings anything like that but I
miss sitting in the changing room after
a game that you've you know that you've
just slogged away with uh 15 20 of your
mates and then having a beer I I really
miss that I really miss the comaraderie
you know the the friendships that you
build through rugby um so yeah that's
the stuff you Pine for um the rugby
itself you know it's a byproduct you
know yeah if I if I have to if I have to
play a game to to get into the sheds and
have a beer later then I'll do that yeah
um and I was I was always Keen to go to
the wheels fell off and um you know the
old the old left one did they've fallen
off well and through but now you're also
doing a bit of throwing like um New
Zealand Rugby throwing coach is that is
that right yeah so um did some work with
the Crusader boys when Jay Ryan was here
and then when he went up into the all
black stuff he he liked what I was doing
so got me sort of across all the super
franchises um and I really enjoy that
the the coaching aspect for me at the
moment uh really busy in life outside of
outside of rugby with family and stuff
and I'm really enjoying sitting on the
sidelines with the kids and and seeing
their their sporting stuff go and
putting time into that so the full-time
role of coaching is probably a little
bit too much you know so um it's a good
way of keeping my hand in the game and
and um you know there's all K our
responsibility you basically partner
with knowledge and if boys are to learn
and and do the work then they're going
to get the benefits anyway how old are
your kids um I got a 22y old who's fully
fully adulting now um and down into nen
and then with carolly and my wife I've
got um a 16-year-old daughter and a
14year old boy oh yeah and into the
sideline parenting life at the moment
pretty much so pretty busy Uber and ATM
that's about
it so what what's actually involved with
the um throwing coach do you get to all
the franchises how often would you go
and yeah so this year was a pilot
program oh yeah and so we'll see see if
it sort of um grows and and what we can
get out of it but um I'd like to see it
sort of become a a national program in
terms of what Mike Cron's done with your
scrummaging you know so everyone in the
throughout New Zealand pretty much
scrums the same way um that way by the
time we get the the Young kids
into um super rug under 20s under 19s
they're all throwing the same way and
then you know they've done the work
whereas at the
moment these guys aren't being taught so
we're trying to we're trying to fix guys
who've had no coaching when they should
be sort of halfway to mastering their
Crow so at the moment this year was
purely just Super Rugby and looking
after a couple of couple of guys
underneath and that was consisted of two
trips through the through the season and
um yeah just sort of spending a couple
of days with them who's impressed you
anyone really stood out as a gun thrower
yeah Jack Taylor's um he's a young kid
that's done a lot of work early you know
so so you see him at the moment and in
terms of throwing he's he's good you
know and now it's just going to be
basically he needs time in the saddle he
needs to um Bas basically [__] up a
number of times in game situations where
he's going to learn and get better and
go back to go back to training and you
know and go through those scenarios but
in terms of his technique and his
fundamentals he's really good you know
he just needs to he needs time in the
settle and how does it work for sort of
the more experienced ones who have I
guess kind of mastered their craft or
you sort of hope that at that point in
their career how do you sort of um
adjust or what what are you doing there
yeah it's not so much adjusting there's
there's tips and you know there's
there's sort of fun fundamentals of what
you want to do you want to you know nice
and square balance through the through
the core and you know nice and tight
through their strong um you want to your
flexibility in your shoulders you need
to keep you know um whilst also putting
on size through you know for your other
other core roles so having if you've got
that then you can you can build on that
um some of the some of the older boys
obviously got fly fly bugged bodies you
know so they're they're compensating
with different things and and you know
having gone through that you understand
it you know so you know that you're not
going to be able to throw the same way
or throw the way that you should be if
you can if you can compensate and and
work and it works then you're fine yeah
um but yeah it's uh the the older ones
are an interesting case too because you
don't know you don't know if they're
open to changing because like you say
they they think they've mastered the
craft yeah but if they're not getting
picked for any want of a reason and then
there's something else yeah so you got
to sort of break them down a little but
yeah um most of the guys are really open
to it day yeah how much of it's mindset
like um obviously you're teaching the
skill
um but I I'm guessing a lot of it is in
the moment that mindset and having that
confidence and back yourself yeah and
you've got to go through you've got to
go through hardship to to learn what
it's like and to learn how to get
yourself out of a hole we we talk about
red head blue head and everything like
that and um when you're in that negative
loop it's really hard to get out of um
so having those tools to to rebalance
reenter and and go through then it's
it's um that's key um but also having
the trust that you've done the work um I
remember uh when I was say early early
20s where I was lucky enough to be
selected in the All Blacks um in 2003
when I hadn't really masterman craft
know and so that gave me a false sort of
a false impression that I had and so
when I'm getting told that I'm not
throwing well or I'm a bad thrower I'm
like hang on I'm an all black man so you
know so um having that probably was uh a
little bit early and then so um so now
I've got to try and teach these guys
that you've got to go through hardship
go through the um the [__] at times to
be able to sort of Master your craft and
and go through M absolutely killing um
the line out throwing love that stuff so
um pretty Keen to get to your journey as
I always do and I know we've had your
cousin Robbie FL on um all the true
water lad original listeners will
remember that one still goes down as one
of the greats but um give me a little
bit of a rundown on your upbringing I
know you're from a mad footy family
parents both um guns as well yeah so um
born and bred in viago
and went to South and boy High um Mom
and Dad yeah like you said both rugby
mad my sister played I played you know
so and coming from Dad's family who were
just rugby nuts you know um so that was
always the the path that I was sort of
going to
take um what is it yeah South boy high
was where I sort of started to really
make some inroads Aaron Flynn my uncle
was playing for the Crusaders oh yeah um
so I sort of come home one day and I
realized that I had a little bit of
potential and I said to Mom that I
wanted to have a crack at being a
professional 40 player so what age was
that uh I was about 15 oh yeah 15 15 and
I was just a I was just a hack didn't
train didn't do anything and um and so
mom's first words to me were we going to
have to work a lot [__] harder before
that happens you know yeah and um so
yeah so that was that was sort of my
start um first 15 sou boys I got a trial
for that and I was playing flanker um
and basically got told that uh one of my
best mates Jeff right he was going to
make the team as a seven and I was I
wasn't going to make it oh [__] but if I
wanted to changed a hooker then there
was a spot there so Peter scout who's
he's still coaching at the moment he's
the the Messiah there um and I'll be
forever thankful for him you know he
sort of put me on that path and rest his
history yeah how didd you find going
into hooker um well I was coming off
rowing I was I was a rower as well so um
big long neck you know
just probably everything that shouldn't
be thrown in the front row um told Mom
and Dad said Dad I said oh look um got a
chance of playing hook I won't make it
as as a seven but have a hook and he's
like not a chance yeah so um were you
big no really yeah skinny well you know
rowing South we you know just racing
sardin so um yeah he's like no you know
no chance in hell obviously being the
protective father yeah um but then I was
like well I'm doing it so we need to
sort this out and he put me in um in
touch with a guy Lex Chisum who used to
play for Southland as well and he gave
me n exercises everything like that and
yeah it was uh I just never looked back
basically were you trying to become a
professional rugby player at this point
is that what you're thinking yeah that
was it was in the back of my head um and
and so that was the that was the start
yeah and I was like oh well if this is
the way it's going to be then I'm going
to have to play hooker yeah so um yeah
the the goal stayed the same but it was
just a different position I was gone in
and what was the hardest part of
adapting to being a hooker um the
throwing would be would have been the
hardest part and then just basically the
soreness of the the body in terms of
your neck shoulders just getting thrown
into a scrum and those those scrums back
in the day were um a completely
different setup to what we got now yeah
but um yeah was that'd be the that'd be
the biggest thing but school boy footy
it wasn't it wasn't massive collisions
you know back then but these guys that
are out there playing now
you knowlet already it is crazy so where
did you get your drive from like
obviously the drive to want to become
Pro like where did that come from cuz
something obviously referencing Robbie
um Robbie was obviously a very talented
player had zero Drive compared to you
sounds like less talented but incredible
drive to try and um make it happen yeah
I don't know I suppose um having having
family that go before you know like Dad
had played for Southland mom had played
for
Southland um few of the uncles had
played for Southland or
canbury or had played for the Crusaders
so seeing those guys go before you knew
that there was ability there was ability
there um and I think
also rowing really gave me the drive
because you you had the ability to work
harder than you've ever worked before
yeah so um you were fit and then when
you were fit I've read MC's book you
know and he was told um the fitter you
get the more enjoyment you have and so
and that's true because all of a sudden
you're touching the ball more you're
making more tackles and it's like look
this game's easy you know and so so that
happens um and then I suppose that is
you know that that sort of
um basically drives the drive as well
you know you're just like well this
actually I could have a decent crack at
this and then you're away and back then
once you're in the system then you you
sort of you got looked after as well um
so I made New Zealand 16s and then from
there I was in the system and went
through schools 19s 21s and yeah was
there ever a decision where you had to
choose rowing or rugby or was rowing
ever an option for you no well as you
know mate I'm not the tallest of the
tallest of people but um it was it was
purely I did it because my mates my best
mates were doing it um that's how I sort
of fell into it Callum rage he he said
I'll come and do it you know and I was
like yeah well don't know what it is but
let's go and it's sort of like a drug as
well because and it's addictive because
as soon as you get in there at the start
it's horrendous you don't know what
you're doing but as soon as you start
clicking everyone's moving in the same
same uh same motion and and you start
getting fast then you think oh [__] I
like this yeah and then um when you
start racing and if you win a couple or
you go well then you just like you're
hooked that's way so um Rowan gave me
the ability to really dig deep and work
hard and um and I and yeah so nothing
that I did in rugby sort of was as hard
as what we trained in rowing yeah um and
yeah I think that was the that was the
biggest key that's interesting I gave
you that sort of Base um you know
mentally and physically on how far you
can push yourself yeah and that's the
thing because you know your body's
always got more yeah um there's times
when you rowing see we were we were 10K
bike ride to get out to the river oh
[__] you know and then we'd go and row
to the second bridge which was like
18K sort of nine there and back yeah and
then our coach would make us go for a
run afterwards and have to bike home so
you know you you're pulling some massive
miles um and Mom and Dad when I'd come
home I'd have two plates of food on the
pot just on Steam you know and I'll just
mow that see you later and then you're
wa yeah and so I think I I I
wholeheartedly believe that um that Ryan
gave me the ability to put myself in a
real dark hole and just then get through
oh that's cool and so I know you played
for Southland young how did that um come
about um played first 15 out of high
school into Club rugby and then um but I
signed up to Southland
earlier um broke my leg and I think it
was the first year I was playing both
hooker and um and open side oh yeah and
I was trialing we had a trial game for
South London brma League that year how
was that how was that to deal with yeah
that was pretty tough um but I hadn't I
hadn't had a break cuz I was summer
winter summer winter just gotone mad
through um through the high school stuff
and so it was my first break that I
really had um and probably went a little
bit harder on the McDonald's and stuff
like that put on I put on about 10K did
yeah yeah it was good fet yeah we to
work that one
off but um yeah and that was
just uh I suppose not being out to deal
with the um the injury as best is
probably what I could have but also not
having not had a break for so long I
just Ved you know yeah um but yeah it
was um it was one of those things that I
look back on and um you think geez I
could have done that a little bit better
but learned from it yeah it is what it
is um and then so that was uh first year
out of out of school and then the year
after that played Club again and
90 uh was it 2001 I think yeah 2001
played um NPC and then got trapped up to
Crusaders for 2002 what was that NPC
year like it was tough yeah um El Stags
we B
away but a lot of fun lot of fun and it
taught me it taught me to celebrate your
wins as well because playing for South
you never know when they're going to
come you know um so when you did yeah
you enjoyed it and um we had a couple of
good wins we beat we beat Wellington up
there that year and um hadn't done that
in something like 50 years and so you
really enjoyed those those times with
the lads but um yeah boys that I played
with down there still still great mates
with today was it an easy decision to
come up to the Crusaders was that the
only real option for you or did you have
a decision at that point um it was a
massive decision to walk away from South
oh yeah because so you had to do canib
as well was that part of the deal yeah
so um at the moment the boys can play
NPC where they want and you know but up
here uh back then it was we had to be
signed for NPC in the Crusaders region
or the Highlanders region and La M's
come down and he said oh look I'll uh
we're going to we're going to shift Tom
Willis up to the Chiefs because he wants
to get some more game time so there's
going to be an option there playing for
the Highlanders really like you to come
you know come and play for us but by
then I'd already been drafted up to the
Crusaders and had a taste of it m and
and I was just like you know thanks but
don't know the only thing that was
holding me to Southland was all of my
mates and mom and dad like that you know
they Southland mad um Dad more so but um
but you know so we had that um I knew
the
the um I suppose the chance of becoming
an all black was higher in the Crusade
or in Christ Church but I still had my
loyalty to the Stags and you know it was
a massive it was so tough um
and then I remember at the time when
when I had actually signed with canbury
there was newspaper articles that the
big money of you know the big unions had
won and everything like that yeah and I
had to hold all the information that I
had because I knew it wouldn't you know
it wouldn't help the situation and
people just cuz you know um at that time
there wasn't many guys coming out of
South and
rugby um but the money that the money
that canb were offering compared to the
money that South were offering was way
lower oh true yeah yeah um and
so um yeah I had to sort of bite my
tongue there that hurt like people that
know me will know that I like to I like
to sort of put my case forward or and if
if I know that it's right I'll I'll
voice it yeah but um yeah that was one
thing that really got
me but you know I look back at it now
and it's it's one of those things that
at the time you think it's all
encompassing and really important but
it's not you know and it's only
hindsight that that gives you that
ability yeah um Deany Robbie Deans at
the time he said to me cuz I you know I
was struggling with my decision and he
said he said look mate those at mine
that those that mind don't matter and
those that matter don't mind so talk to
the people that you're closest with and
then you'll come up with your decision
and for me that was really that was
great advice because you know 20 21
years old you're not a you're not
equipped to deal with that sort of uh
that sort of dilemma and so yeah so
talking to Mom and Dad and and the
people that really mattered the most
that's when we decided to come up and
and what was it like coming into this
environment for the first time oh m i
was I had always like dinner plate day
um like I walked into my first preseason
training so you know how you you join
together in the December before the
Christmas break yeah and it wasn't too
bad because all the All Blacks were gone
oh yeah so there was only a skeleton
crew of us and there was a few new boys
there was me Brad maer um
Johny and you know so we were Nick white
um who else was there so we were the
sort of the greenh horns the first years
yeah and we're like oh it was pretty
cool and then after the Christmas break
all the big dogs Marshall Mertens you
know all those boys coming I was like
holy hell yeah you know now we're in now
we're in business sort of thing and yeah
I mean those guys were awesome um and
I'd been I'd been sort of watching them
on TV the year before and all of a
sudden I'm standing the same gym and um
and it's it's quite funny because you
see it when you're older and you see the
young kids coming in and that was like
[__] hell yeah but um having you know
having been through that then you've got
more empathy too for the the young ones
coming through and you and you sort of
throw them under the wing and and just
get them in but yeah I still remember it
day it was pretty cool did you feel like
you were good enough to be there um
I suppose externally you do you know you
portray that
you that yeah
yeah I should be here but internally
you're not yeah you're just thinking
holy hell especially when you see a guy
like Ruben Thorn who um immensely strong
you know like and he's throwing weights
around like yeah wouldn't believe
and um and I'm sitting there never sort
of really been on the bench press holy
[__] so when you sit there and you think
[__] I've got a way to go here yeah but
I suppose that's the beauty about the
environment
is um they're accommodating you know and
so they know that everyone coming in
isn't going to be right there or then
but if say Well in that time if Den's
picted you then he's seen that there's
something there um yeah so yeah it's a
it was pretty awesome yeah and it all
happened really quick for you too like
um I don't know if it's following That
season um probably one of the real true
bolers going to a Rugby World Cup um
yeah how was that um yeah that
was that
was scary to be honest yeah you know
like um like I said I was only 21 and I
was going the World Cup yeah you know I
I remember I had a lot of things that I
was dealing with at the time because I
just signed to come up here full time so
cuz in those days if you didn't make it
you'd get a phone call and so I was I
just bought a house um up here in Christ
Church and I was in the house and um get
this phone call unknown number and I
good I like Yi it's um it's MIT you mate
um uh you got a minute to talk and I was
like oh yes H I was like oh yeah I said
um he goes just want to know how you you
know how your injuries come along and
cuz I'd broken my arm oh yeah and want
to know how your injuries come along and
um you know when you were back plan I
said I actually got a club game next
week and you know all going well should
be you know back into it he said sweet
and um I thought I'd just ring you just
out of courtesy just to let you know
that you made the All Blacks for the
World Cup I was like yeah it's cool man
was just coming off the injury it didn't
really didn't really even come into my
my thinking so he's like yeah know
that's cool um we'll keep in touch with
your injury and and your um return to
play and stuff like that and we'll go
from we'll just keep in touch I was like
cool no worries thanks for that and he
goes oh just um just by chance how's the
shoulder I was like shoulder and he goes
yeah yeah said well I said he um I broke
my arm that's my injury was my M and M
goes who's this I said it's fenny Cory
fenny goes he said I told him a p to
ring Hy uh to get me to get me H's
number oh hell so she must have heard
Cory so he Rings me and then he's like
oh well while I've got the phone um just
want to let you know that you come to
World Cup and I'm like what so I'm
sitting here Absol I've gone I've rid
the roller coaster and um yeah so he he
told me then and there and he said look
you can't can't let anyone know um can't
let anyone know but you know you come to
World Cup I was like you said the press
release is 6:00 tonight so watch the
news with your you know with the people
that matter jeez that is crazy so I got
off the phone rang mom and dad and I
said you've got to be watching the
news and basically did cartwheels around
the empty
house so he called you thinking you were
Hy yeah to tell you that you weren't
going yeah far and you obviously weren't
expecting to make it at all like you say
you've just come into the Crusaders
feeling a little bit uncomfortable yeah
now you're off to a Rugby World Cup and
that's the thing like I said earlier you
know I I hadn't mastered anything you
know I'd
basically I was a beneficiary of being
in a in a super environment like the the
Crusaders um so yeah it was I mean
hindsight it was too early yeah you know
but um it was also a hell of an eye open
and a lot of fun as well yeah so when
you're doing your cartwheels and
celebrating the fact that you're now an
all black when does that sort of turn to
oh [__] I'm I've got the country um
needing me to perform at this Rugby
World Cup here yeah um I suppose it
wasn't until we lost the semifinal that
you really understood the magnitude of
it yeah
um because up until then I still didn't
really have a lot of the pressure on me
that the big boys had because I was a
Bolter I was young I was um I was seen
as a development sort of project
so um yeah never really felt that
absolute pressure until he lost and then
basically the world imploded yeah and
the All Blacks were hated and it's like
w Jesus this is actually really
important yeah you know and so so seeing
that that that's when you really knew
the the importance of the All Blacks
doing well at World Cups and what was
that like for you at such a young age to
go through all that
um again probably didn't appreciate it
as much as what I could have you know
because you know like I I automatically
thought well I'm 21 I got four more
years I'll be 25 yeah just I you know
potentially I could be 29 and go to
another one you know and
so I I didn't actually think that it was
all that bad yeah you know because I
thought I was going to have another
crack but obviously then being on the
other end of it and say 2011 knowing
that was potentially my last um you sort
of know how important it is and how you
should appreciate it um but yeah I I
mean a lot of my a lot of my younger
career
um I you know I would have I would have
loved to have that' probably be the one
thing that I changed yeah would be that
and being as diligent or being as
appreciative of everything that's coming
yeah cuz it's interesting how I look at
your um career and all black career and
it sort of spans over like nine years
and you look at the how many caps and
it's 15 caps so and and that was the
like there's
there's the the injuries um and then
there's the
um the not mastering the craft early
yeah that didn't set me out well enough
you know um because when you're young
and you get it early you do have a bit
of a you do have a bit of an
overinflated ego of yourself you know
and then so I'm impression of yourself
sorry so you give it um it takes a lot
of it takes a lot of smacking to break
that out of you and and um you know
whether it be injuries or non selections
you got to you've essentially got to
rebuild you know and I think um that was
the one thing that um that I would have
changed yeah what did that look like for
you coming out of there and what would
how would you have changed it well I
would have like if if ID had the ability
to I suppose
learn mcraft hone it for another 3 years
then I would have been well equipped to
have a crack it um for was it 2007 you
know but um in that time where I should
have been mastering I was um thinking
that I was better than what I was yeah
and then on top of that I also had
injuries that I was having to deal with
mentally um um and that was hard yeah
you know and so not not having the not
having the ability to have confidence in
what I was doing on the field or um and
then dealing with the injuries then it
just you know just snowballed and ended
up ended up not getting the best out of
me yeah and I mean you did have a
terrible run of injuries really didn't
you like there's a patch there where it
was just seemed to be injury after
injury and you talk about how hard that
was to deal with um what does that look
like
like um that looks
like well a probably a kid that should
be hitting at straps you know um playing
some of the best footy that he's playing
that he's
played and and really going and making a
fist of it to a guy
probably broken on the inside physically
and half broken mentally knowing that
he's not able to do what he should be
doing um and then you're getting paid
like a professional you're amateur in a
a big sense of the word because you
think back
2002 through to I suppose 2008 2009 is
when we really started getting
professional yeah so getting paid really
well and then probably well not probably
but pissing up too much you know because
that was the way that you dealt with it
um um Crusaders Mantra and back in those
days was work hard play hard it was the
old DB the DB logo you know um so you
get into that cycle and like I say that
redhe head blue head you're getting that
negative Loop and you just you just stay
in it you stay in it and then you
basically you build um or you cement
those um those routines and that's just
what it is and then so I went through
obviously I think four on one arm and
one on the other you know so I did that
five times that's crazy yeah and then I
had cind asmosis I had shoulders you
know so every time I was just on that
Loop um and then you know so like I said
I touched back on not honing my craft so
when I was coming back and getting into
playing
because I didn't have all of my Big
Blocks
sorted um when I was when I was tell
when I was told by coaches and
everything like that that I was missing
out cuz I'm a throwing but they were
picking players like say Anella dealm
mon who was knowing that he wasn't a
good thrower yeah but I'd been picked
earlier because I was good enough but
now I'm told that my thr's not to stand
we hang on yeah but again
I thought that my Big Blocks were in
place but because I was told you know um
but they weren't essentially yeah and
then yeah so that was and that's all in
coming that just that's extra weight and
then you're back in that Loop yeah um
and yeah so I think that was that was my
biggest uh learning later on coming out
um and getting I suppose a Redemption a
Redemption then yeah that's what I
learned most and when you're in there
you mentioned the drinking like what did
that look like was that how often was
that well you know like we'd be after
after every away game for the Crusaders
we'd have a court session you know like
we'd be locked down into every week in
2002 yeah 2002 we we went through
unbeaten yeah and lockdowns yeah and so
we had um what' we do we every away game
we'd have a a court session and you know
it only be an hour yeah it wasn't it
wasn't massive amounts of drinking it
was more getting the boys in getting
tight but if you want to have a few
beers you
could and so um I was never one to shy
away from it so um yeah we uh we'd get
into it and and that was and then in
2003 when um we come back I remember cuz
we went through unbeaten and I remember
sitting in this room is our meeting room
and Darren Shand who's obviously just
finished up at the All Blacks now he was
our manager then and he was trying to
get us to be more professional at that
time and so he's sitting there and he
goes right boys you know like we had a
good year last year went through
P said just sit in the scene for going
forward I think we should start looking
getting a little bit more professional
what that looks like not pussing up as
much right Justin Marshall sitting in
the back back row on in the front row
the new boy and then um Shandy's sitting
there doing his bit up the front and
Marshall's like Shandy we're Crusaders
we work hard we play hard sit
down you know I'm 22 years old in the
side I'm going yeah
boy so you know and like knowing what we
know now yeah that wasn't the right
thing to do you know but at the time it
was like wow
awesome so yeah bloody H case um
but yeah yeah so how did you how did you
get out of that cycle like eventually
you talk about the Redemption story like
what flicked for you well I hit rock
bottom to be truthfully honest yeah um
yeah so when would that have been [__]
about
2008 2009 okay okay um it was quite not
funny but it was interesting looking
back on it now the boys or the people in
the know were waiting for it to happen
you know so um Caroline my wife she was
about ready to up sticks and leave with
the kids and and stuff so pretty much
gave me an
ultimatum I rung up Dave hu who was the
professional development manager at the
time yeah and I said tiger I need help
um I need help meate and he could sense
it in my voice that something bad had
happened and he was like I'll be there
in 5 minutes hung up the phone and he
was at my house in 5 minutes um and we
basically sat down went through
everything and went from there um they
were apparently ready to go they knew
that something was going to happen and I
was going to need help um so they were
they had everything sort of just ready
to go and then boom they had the go
button and I was in I was at in a
counselor that afternoon um talking to
talking to um a drug and alcohol
counselor and then yeah that was that
was the start of the Redemption I
suppose crazy how so how did they all
know and were you aware of how close you
were to being Rock botom no not at all
and that's the thing it wasn't until
even even so even at that point I
probably wasn't I probably didn't
understand how close I was either M um
it wasn't until it wasn't until um kolly
sat down in front of the counselor with
me in the room and basically told her a
story and that was that was the shotgun
in the face yeah I was like [__] here we
go yeah um so that was yeah that was the
that was the time
that um that really got me yeah was it
an addiction or so what was it um I
suppose addiction potentially is
definitely there um I mean but it's also
just like I'm a lad you know Escape type
yeah yeah and being being with the lads
having beers like there's nothing better
you know but it's that it's it's being
able to rain it in and stuff like that
so I mean as it stands to today I've
I've been off the piss since January
because I'd sort of got into into the
same sort of um I suppose routines yeah
yeah so I've just knocked off the puss
again and just a I suppose a reset but
um to show you've still got control of
yeah and and um because you don't like
obviously with the kids at the ages that
they're at they're the ones missing out
and um you know so yeah just sort of
trying to make sure that you got the
most important things in your life um
when you need them yeah M that's
powerful so when you you go see the
counselor and then the whole Redemption
starts yeah what does that look like um
so knocked off the booze um I I sort of
said to K look I'll do I'll do a
year um sober was that
hard uh yeah it was yeah at the start it
was um
because back then there was no alcohol
zero beers yeah you know zero alcohol
beers so every time like for 3 months I
didn't basically leave the house it was
work train that you know and then that
was it yeah um but then slowly but
surely you you're not really you know
you're not really worried about having a
beer or something like that but when you
do go out you've got nothing in your
hands you know what do I
do and everybody if you haven't got
anything in your hand everyone's like oh
do you want a drink MBE no no I'm not
drinking why you drinking yeah tell the
whole
story well where do you want me to
start um so so that was that was tough
at the moment like now it's it's sweet
because you can zero a cold beer but
it's also widely accepted that people
don't drink anymore yeah you know so
it's it's not a big deal now yeah but
yeah back then it was yeah I bet um um
and especially knowing me as a person
knowing that I'm uh that I love being
out with the lads and stuff like that
yeah you know people were a little bit
worried
yeah um but yeah so that that was what
that was sort of what
transpired um did the did the one year
but once I'd got to the one year
everything else started falling into
place and I remember I remember the old
lady telling me uh um she's like Cory
anytime things happen in your life
that's bad it's all around alcohol and
I'm like yeah whatever mom you know yeah
I didn't want to hear it at that time
but obviously once uh once I sort of got
clear and and everything like that then
you remember those things and so got to
the year everything had started working
out pretty well I had um hadn't been
injured planing some good footy so I was
like well I might as well just have a
crack it maybe getting into this world
cup and doing that so sort of went on to
the end of the world cup yeah and did
you feel like you were a good chance to
make that World Cup no no I didn't think
[__] show oh really yeah I had um when I
was when I was approaching Rock Bottom
um we had oh we had a a test match in
denen and um
and I uh was down there as a part of um
DB in the corporate box and beside us
there was another corporate box but and
in that one cuz it was after 2007 you
know and then in the Box beside us
Graham Henry's wife was in there um
Rowan and I didn't know this but and so
I'm half shitfaced probably fulltime sh
face and um and once they lost that game
I thing was against the Box they lost
that game um I was like I should have
got rid of them you know should have got
rid of them [__] after 2007 oh [__]
and she saw this she heard this and you
know like knowing how protective my mom
you know my wife is of my career yeah
you know how protective um you know each
each person's wives or you know closest
people are of their own husbands fathers
and um I got I got a phone call the next
day from um from someone inside the All
Blacks Camp basically said you made a
bit of a dick yourself I had no had no
clue oh you didn't know you'd said it
there didn't I knew that I'd said it but
I didn't know who was you know so I was
like oh it just it's just what it was
anyway got a phone call um you said a
few things uh in the box and I was like
probably half pussed full pussed and
then he said yeah well Graham Henry's
wife was in the other box and then that
sinking feeling just
comes anxiety comes it's like oh
no so that was you know that was
2008 um the first test I suppose and so
from that I was on the back burner and
geez you did well to make it after that
that's a rough start and rightly so you
know like um
yeah I
remember you know
cuz like I know I'm not an [__] of a
person but I had to own it because like
IID made that I'd made that mistake and
I was like oh yeah right out so got put
out to pasture and um slowly but surely
started making
inroads um after hitting the
bottom and then play started coming back
and obviously having the likes of your
mcco your Brad Thorns DC's all those
guys that I'm working with at the
Crusaders day and day out and then um
they were looking for a third option
with the All Blacks because they hadn't
settled on one yeah and then so the boys
B went into bat for me um and said look
you know this guy's [__] made some
changes and R ra and so I got another
crack and
um well that was some of the most scary
I've ever been was it yeah you know cuz
I'd never seen I'd never seen Ted or
anything beforehand leading into it so
this was the first time you'd met him
since the conversations and all that
well yeah and got called in got called
into to a camp and then the first people
I walk into an an elevator Graham Henry
ran Henry I'm
like hadn't seen
anyone just start sweating buets what do
you doing
I thankfully that it was only us three
in the in the elevator yeah and I just
had to swallow my pride apologize FR her
yeah and I just said look um you know
there were things said I said I'm so
sorry I shouldn't have said it you know
yeah right Ted shook my hand and said no
he said it's
forgotten just you know make it good and
that was it and I was like oh yeah Raven
didn't say a thing to me yeah and so I
knew that it wasn't awful
G um you know so had that um and then
you think too all the wives and everyone
they get invited to stuff and and that
sort of thing and so when car had been
introduced to rayan she didn't give her
the shirt you know didn't give her the
steam offer ship because yeah she was
you know she was assigned to me yeah so
it was really tough for kol and you know
so for those next couple of years I was
just yeah pushing [__] up hill with a
rake um but you know to Ted's credit
never had to he never had to take me
back in yeah um and I'm forever thankful
for for doing it um after we won the
World Cup I was sitting there having a I
I actually my first beer and I was
sitting there having a beer and ran come
up to me and sort of tap me on the
shoulder and she said um Cory
appreciate what you're done appreciate
owning it it's forgotten and I was like
it was seriously like the weight of the
world had just gone off my shoulders you
know but yeah so having like having all
that hang over here yeah [__] burate
yeah um and carrying that sort of that
sort of luggage
around yeah it's not good it's not good
for the cell that is crazy and I know
like in the Crusade environment you were
like um you were a real leader like you
you'd say what was on your mind you were
um one of those type of types of players
going into the All Blacks did you feel
like you could still do the same or did
you have to just sit sit up the front
shut your mouth and just do what you
told yeah
I and I think um by the end of it you
know by the end of
2011 um I felt that I deserve my place
here yeah um
and I was comfortable you know
contributing and everything like that um
earlier on say 2003 2004 that sort of
stuff I didn't even think I should have
been in all black so there was no way um
and but yeah when I first got when I
first got back in after my Hiatus yeah I
was just Z
it but it's easier too when when you've
got the ear of the likes of
or someone that I could ever talk to
Behind Closed Doors know then but um but
yeah the old blacks for me was a
different was a different experience in
terms
of um never really felt like I
belonged um up until the the final of
the World Cup you know and sitting there
on the field really appreciating my
journey of getting back there and seeing
everyone sort of celebrating and um and
I remember shag coming up to me and
shaking my hand and give me a hug and go
well done you know like you know you
just had that satisfaction I was like oh
thank [__] for that yeah yeah I haven't
been a [__] up all my
life but yeah um that's when that's when
I sort of got the feeling
of that's what that's what the likes of
MC and those guys that established
that's what they must feel like you know
when they come into this environment
because that you felt like you belonged
yeah well I did I felt like I belonged
at that point yeah and obviously getting
to win um Rugby World Cup not a not an
easy thing to do and um pretty special
yeah it was it was and and there was the
thing though like you say you know when
you when you get there and you and you
achieve it you understand or you really
appreciate what you've given up and
what's
what's transpired to get you into that
point and that's when you really that's
when you really start to appreciate
stuff did you I was just thinking around
um Izzy and CJ through that World Cup
and um I'm guessing you could probably
you probably had a bit of empathy for
them did you did you have a word word to
them or what was your advice to those
guys once they'd gone through all that
uh I actually one of my mates had um had
come across as he and and at the time oh
yeah and so he rang me I had Miss phone
calls from him I was like what the
hell's this and so I rang him back the
next day and he's like he's like bro um
I don't think CJ and Izzy are going to
be in good States today and I was like
so he told me the story yeah and so I
was like oh y right out so went and went
off to find
azy and I remember seeing him he was
white as a
guy jeez bro you look you look worse for
we
yeah and um and so yeah so we were
sitting there and he sort of told me
about what had happened and
then um everything that sort of come in
afterwards was the biggest shock for
them
like me saying or me coming down on them
wasn't going to you um I remember we got
called into the team
room everybody knew knew what had
happened and then mcco stood up in front
of the team and basically his CJ and izy
I think they're up the front but they
just sitting there like little school
kids and and Rick just deal to them he's
like who the [__] do you think you are
you know and from then cuz this was
early too like this was pretty much
straight away as soon as it
happened everyone
just
Jesus everyone knew and and so from
there no one had to say anything yeah um
but yeah it was it was one of those
things the biggest thing was s Smithy
who the you know he had done so much and
he just couldn't he couldn't comprehend
what had happened he was like why would
they do that you know but everyone
everyone who is an izy CJ type of
Personality were like yeah I could see
how that would happen you know but the
likes of mcco or um Smithy those type of
personalities yeah they just like what
the [__] yeah you know and I suppose
that's a beauty about a rugby team is
that you've got so many different
personalities
100% um but
yeah it it was an interesting time and
had you signed to go over to France at
this point or was that after you made
that decision after no so I just started
playing pretty good footy and it was on
the back of being fresh you know having
a good run of injury free that sort of
thing like I remember when tody black
had to come in um I was in and out with
injury and stuff like that leading into
I think I think 2010 he sits me down and
he goes well we need have a Yar he said
um I've invested pretty heavily in you
and you haven't my my rate rate of
return of investment is
uh probably [__] minimal yeah I like
yeah cool so we come up with a plan and
he said look I just want you to get
through a game he said don't worry about
anything in terms of how you planing
said just come just walk off the field
and be able to suit up for me the next
day and so um for the next six weeks
that's what he did every every oneon-one
that I had with him he's like cool
success yeah you're not injured got
through
it how' you do that Fu I don't know but
it was all the pressure you know like
the pressure of hitting lineups pressure
of playing well it's like [__] you know
so everything is all bound up yeah okay
um and then slowly but surely he started
he started putting a little bit more on
me and then so by that time I was in the
groove and I was away um and then so
yeah so everything followed on
2011 and I was I was just flying I was
humming so I started thinking him what
am I doing am I staying or am I going
and so stayed on for another couple of
years uh we we 2012 and then um yes
signed for another couple of years after
that got to
2014 halfway through the season got
called into the into the Big Dog's
office with um there was Dave hu Toddy
and Richard Smith RJ who was at that
time I'm the contracts
manager and
um and they said
oh uh what's your plans for next year I
said oh don't know mate hopefully play
pretty well and maybe go to a World Cup
and they said oh yeah I said look I'd
really love to stay on and um stay on
and retire as a crusader you know be a
one club man see you later so they said
oh yeah okay um RJ goes well next year
we don't see you starting for the
Crusaders I was
like well what have I
[Music]
missed I
said we're
midseason we're mid the end of season
yeah um I looked at Toddy and I said toy
if we go through semi-finals or anything
who's starting hooker he said you are I
said okay so if we go to the final I
start at Hooker how in that time do I
not do I lose my my spot it just doesn't
make sense to me yeah and then uh big Go
season
yeah I think I've got things in
check so um then you obviously RJ s
takes a lead and says well we've got Ben
Fel Cody Taylor and everything like that
coming through and I said understand
that I said but they're not they're not
ready to go just yet said give me that
time get let me have another year at uh
you know having number one and then
going through two and you know see see
see a way out but they didn't give me
sort of that Assurance they were like oh
well we don't see us B number one next
year so we're going to cut your contract
by x amount and I was like Jesus that
was a [__] that was a shot in the
face it's brutal he especially
considering you're playing so well yeah
and um and so especially yeah and like
for me to take that was that was tough
you know but um it was also easier
because of everything that I'd been
through as well and I was s like oh well
this is this is what it is Curly will
probably tell you different but um you
know it did it did Cut Me To The Bone
yeah because you see you see how much
effort you put in while you're here and
then all of a sudden you just realize
that you're you're a commodity and it's
like oh well okay once you accept that
then it's
yeah um and I think that's the that's
the difference now with boys I suppose
is that they're professional enough to
know that it's not forever and it's just
a business whereas the amateur to
professional you still had the Loyalty
factor that you thought you you sort of
bound by deserved yeah especially what
games yeah um and you know and and it
was because I didn't think that I was
asking for too much that I didn't
deserve yeah you know like if I wasn't
playing well if you know then I would
have accepted I would have been like go
but I just couldn't understand how I'd
go from an off seon to to not being
starting or number one hooker yeah um
and yeah it was um that was the biggest
thing and not having the likes of black
out to sort of stand up and say actually
flyy know you are my number one was like
well cuz I gave him the opportunity to
do it yeah but he didn't I like hey old
bastard so um yeah so that was that so
France it was yeah and then just by
chance um about a week later Warren
orock was here doing something and I was
walking past him he goes oh sit down I
was like oh yeah and he goes um how's
everything going I said oh well you've
obviously heard about what's happening
here and he he goes yeah he goes um well
have you ever thought about a move to
France is it all no but what have you
got so he said well to Los are
interested on a medical Joker cuz Chile
boy rali had bust his knee oh yeah um
and
so he told me what that what that
entailed it was only going to be like a
six-month contract and I was like no I'm
not doing that and then so he went back
to them and basically said he'll come
for the medical Joker if you guarantee
another year so yeah we did that true um
and yeah loved it loved it it was it was
really cool like at the
start um when K was studying so she she
stayed here for 4 months or something
like that with the kids I went over I
was living with Luke McAllister oh yeah
he was the too the king of to at the
time I bet and um so so had him sort of
help helping me out he he spoke a fair
amount of the language um and then yeah
got set up with a house and got ready
for the kids and K to come over um about
December just before Christmas um and
yeah it was it was good times like there
were um you know he was living in the
right in the middle of toos and we and
but then he bought a house um a little
bit out of too so had the best of both
worlds where in a city living you know
we get home from training and then we're
straight into the the restaurants and
just having you know having feed and
living life sure um and and uh but yeah
then also moved out to the suburbs as
well and understood what it was going to
be like when you know the family come
over and but got a good lay of the land
while while we while while I was here
and what was the FY like was it hard for
you to adjust um yeah it was it was and
um
especially because when you see so to
loose had a star started lineup you know
you had imol heroni Terry du we had
census Johnson Joe
Tori um Patricia albet you know guys who
have played a lot of International Rugby
and that's just the forward pack you
know the backline we had Vincent clerk
um Floren frit G fiku you know so we
like was unbelievable the team that week
could field yeah um but yet it was just
it was just ad hoc you know like it was
play just there was no structure and so
I was sort of like well if we had a
little bit of structure to to ignite
this fare yeah then we're going to rip
[__] to BTS yeah so and at that point we
were um there was the 242 that we had
played in New Zealand for a bit so um
introduced that I said to said to Luke I
was like mate we need to talk to these
boys and and he sort of had a look at it
and he enjoyed it he was like [__] that
that looks all right yeah so took it to
Du and who speaks really good English
and so talked to TT and he was happy to
front it as a captain and and go forward
what we didn't do is go through John
Baptist who was the attack coach okay
and so so we took it to the head coach G
no and then um he was like yep let's do
it so we implemented it without going
through attch coach it was a big
mistake we found out about French rugby
right there and then um and then um
implemented it we started training it
boys took to it like ducks the water you
know you think a little bit of structure
to ignite fare that people play with
anyway it's just going to you know it's
going to flourish and so all of a sudden
because we were just playing around the
corner sending eight forwards you know
scrum around the corner just
play and then um and so giving these
guys SE spots to be in the field where
then we can just go and we played it we
played the first game with the structure
and we scored six OR7 fries and I was
like Master coach we're on we're on and
the were loving it very next week gone
never saw it again oh really oh true The
Tech coach came in yeah squashed
it I like oh well so that was that was
your introduction to French rugby and
basically just shut up and yeah shut up
and do your job and you know go from
there so then you moved to Glasgow yeah
so had had two seasons with um with toos
loved it um lifestyle everything like
that you know cuz I I would never have
moved yeah I would never have moved um
and I would never have experienced it
either so you know beauty of hindsight
I'm quite thankful that RJ and that you
know poo pooed me yeah cuz it wouldn't
have given me that yeah you know um but
having the the ability or having two
years there and my last year I didn't
play a lot my body sort of recovered and
it's not taxing it's physically taxing
because your scrums mes it's a big part
of the game but you're not running
massive meters so your your training
meters aren't massive so my body wasn't
really good neck but the kids were
getting bullied at school they didn't
they didn't like it as much as K and I
were liking it um so we had an option of
going to Glasgow to get the kids back
into English speaking stuff like that so
we went from south of France average
temperature of about
20° up to Glasgow and um yeah that was a
shock did you know you what you're going
into had you had you looked into it or
probably not as much detail as you
should have the weather the weather we
knew I mean coming from inago not not a
not not worried about too much cold but
um yeah the the shock that I got or like
there was there was
basically a New Zealand never trained
and Longs or jackets you know it was
always a thermal in a jersey yeah and
shorts whereas in Glasgow I never got
out of long and a jack and a full Beanie
you know it was uh it was pretty brutal
yeah it was um yeah they I remember um
there was a couple of times
where the Christmas the Christmas period
it was actually mco's wedding I was
meant to come back for it and Gregor
towns and he said oh you we'll we'll let
you we'll let you off um and you can get
back for that wedding
Anyway come time to go for that wedding
he's like oh know we got H Cup coming M
I need you to be available for that yeah
so car and the kids come back into
summer and I'm in I'm in the the heat of
the heat of the Glasgow winter so um I'm
sitting there going a training we're
getting vitamin D pills given to us cuz
the sun only basically goes high enough
to to cover the far 5 m line in sunshine
was pretty
depressing um and so and then I'm
FaceTiming Carol and the kids you know
uh at um in the morning or at night well
yeah at night I suppose and then so
they're in daylight and it's blue skies
flat lakes and I'm just sinking deeper
and deeper into into
depression so um but in terms of as a
whole I really enjoyed Glasgow you know
the People Are Awesome the teammates
that um that I had there were were
Second To None they were they were good
boys um I remember a guy Rory Hughes
he's a he's a Scot Scottish uh Winger
and he he's
wean and I was sitting next to him in
the changing room and everyone's
introducing themselves to me Rosa
introduces himself and he's speaking in
this real like glaswegian accent which I
thought was Italian or
something and so he's sitting there and
he's talking he walks out and I was like
where's all where's all mate from like
it's from Scotland M from GGO I was like
[__]
me can understand cuz we had Simone
favaro as well I can I can understand
Simone way better than this
guy so um yeah so having those guys they
were awesome um really enjoyed the the
company and and having having rugby as
the common denominator it's easy you
know and me as a as a
player I was going to work doing
everything that I was in too or at the
at the Crusaders so for me it was no
different yeah one thing that we did
have was the kids were happy cuz they
were in school and crucial yeah kids
were happy but then kol wasn't cuz she
was going to work at the MC and then so
she's walking in it's dark yeah walking
out in the AR you know she like [__]
miserable so I'm
like but um but yeah so it's it's those
things that you got to away up and we
had signed two years we had signed two
years with glasgo cuz I was like I said
to G I said well the only1 year I might
as well just try and find something in
France for a year and go home after that
so signed two years and then um come to
the end of oh so yeah going into the
into the first year I said look mate you
know I'm 34 35 years old I haven't got
the the runs that I'm I'm not going to
be able to do much running yeah when
he's he says now enough we not going to
run you that much or off field um train
you r r so that was all good soon as I
got there signed I was expected to be
running 5 6K training you know and I was
like here we go here we
go so and the trainer at the time um
tibo Gerard he's a French trainer now
he's a Frenchman and and but he had been
he' been French Bob slay he'd been um
American football oh yeah stuff like so
he knew he knew a lot about training he
was he was awesome and so he would take
me and train me off you know off feet
instead of running and um but because I
wasn't making meters of training I
didn't warrant being pick for the game
oh yeah it was just
that um that sort of high the old hler
Hitler way of coaching oh that's crazy
so obviously people again listening that
know me know that they would
just the coach and I would but AE so um
yeah it was it it was it was hard I
don't know how much I can actually say
but because um of I in order to leave I
had to sign a NDA oh yeah you know so um
but yeah it was it was interesting W
that is crazy yeah and they cuz they
don't have a Players Association over
there they didn't yeah um so it was my
way the highway from from the uh the
management
so which was really really disappointing
because the boys are awesome and they
work [__] they work you know and fit and
strong and you know so if they had a
little bit of buying which I think they
they potentially do now then you could
see where they could go um but you know
like seeing some of the stuff that's
happened since with the likes of Finn
Russell and and um and Gregor and you
seeing the the blowups there it's like
was always
going so cuz I remember we were at
training and um he'd showed they showed
a video and it was of uh the All Blacks
playing a team
and looking at running a hard evens line
and manipulating defense popping the
ball and then someone breaking through
that line yeah they breaking through the
hole I was like [__] this is awesome
this is our game I can do that so anyway
went to run it in um in training took
the ball popped it boy went through got
tackled so blew the whistle GG goes oh
Cory that's not it's not how you do it I
like okay he says you have to catch ball
look and pop it I'm like wa
mebe I'm sitting there and I'm like well
if you look on the video then Karen Reed
we call it lying with your eyes you know
so you're hoing straight there looking
to that Defender no look P because you
want him to bite in on you you know he
says well that's not how we do it here I
like you just told us that you want us
doing it like the o
okay sorry my
bad I didn't say that but in my head
that's what I'm
saying um and then so anyway Sean Lamont
played 100 games for um Scotland um and
he comes up and he's like flny he says
oh if I can give you a piece of advice
don't challenge the
together I really didn't didn't really
he go like he said otherwise you''ll be
playing Club rugby I'm like n surely not
he said trust me anyway next week I'm
playing Club
rugby yeah playing Club rugby and uh
yeah that was that was the beginning of
the end true that's crazy yeah yeah and
and that was a it's a shame because the
likes of um Gregor massive knowledge you
know but if he if he had the ability to
not be so much as well the highway yeah
huge huge potential there as a coach and
he probably sto he probably still could
be but the boys will only take the
Hitler approach for so long and then and
then they'll start they'll start pulling
away but um because they had because the
boys won they they lived in fear of them
because you obious you know yeah you're
going and playing Club rugby if you
don't yes sir no sir yeah but also um
they had had some success as well but
that was on the back of the other
coaches before and the culture that they
built and he was just slow eroding that
that's interesting it's fascinating yeah
it's just a shame and then um but then
you know when Dave reny come in
um he had a good culture Were You There
When R the year after I got I got sick I
got sick uh the year before yeah um when
he when he come in and I was gutted cuz
I I'd been beaten by Dave in 2011
2012 um or sorry 12 and 13 and so I was
Keen to learn and and actually be under
him and see what the [__] made those
Chiefs so good in those years you know
but um yes I was a little bit gutle
about that um but yeah and
then um yes that was the the the
beginning of the end sort of challenging
the gaffer
and yeah I learned I learned a lesson
there quickly and then I guess your wife
would have been happy you did because
brings you back to New Zealand right and
then you're playing for West Coast yeah
yeah so yeah so we we got through I got
a disciplinary hearing request from
Glasgow and um then so went through all
of that um
and we were about to go on holiday and
I'd been asked to play for the barbar oh
yeah and so um I rang Dave reny because
he was the coach of the following year
oh yeah so I rang Dave reny and said B
been asked to play for the bar I what's
your thoughts on that and knowing full
well that probably should have asked
Gregor but he wasn't going to be the
coach cuz he was going to Scotland yeah
knowing Gregor would have said not a
[__] [__] now yeah so rang Dave and
he's yeah don't see a problem with that
mate y so said to uh ver cot yeah I'm
available right R then it got through
back to um Gregor and he said um why
didn't you ask me said well you're not
the coach next year mate so thought of
be the person that directly affects and
and yeah he wasn't he wasn't that happy
so then um so then basically that's when
it all [__] erupted [__] and then we
were about to go on holiday but we had
all this hanging over our head and then
they they called me and offered me a
settlement and then that was it it was
basically right don't have to spend
another winter in Scotland yeah didn't
really see a career ending like this so
well but you know yeah but did you try
and play back here um yeah no it was the
settlement that I got allowed us to come
home
reset let me get the kids away to school
all that sort of stuff decompress yeah
and then I was just going to start
looking at life after footy yeah um had
Sean cuts at the time he was a coach and
he said would you think about coming and
playing for the coast and I was like oh
well I plan to play this year anyway so
um yeah why not
and um harder on the liver than it was
you
know physically anywhere else yeah but
um it was awesome yeah you know gave me
a real appreciation of um Grassroots
rugby again because when you're in it
for so long and professional stuff for
so long you you forget what it was like
back in the day and when you working you
know working your 9 to5 and then we had
guys um Dan Davies he was he was driving
2 hours from Hast to come up and train
you know and just all purely for the
love of it crazy so cool so you see that
you see what guys what guys give up and
sacrifice just to play footy and it
gives you a real love again because and
and having that where um where I'd been
sacked I was a little bit pissed off um
I was a bit bitter so going back into
that gave me the love again and um and
really enjoyed and gave me the ability
just to sign off on the way that I
wanted to it's a cool way to do it and
everyone who has done it has spoken so
highly of playing um Heartland yeah it
is I mean and that's the thing like if
your body if your body's still in check
then you got that you know like I'd
recommend it yeah it is cool and you
give so much back um you know and
physically you're probably you're
definitely not able to do what you used
to be able to do but you can still you
can still get away with um what you need
to at that level I remember playing we
went up to roria and played the coast s
it was awesome you know and so we're
playing the game and I was holding on to
I was holding on to the flanker who was
the captain at the time and hold him
into the Rock and he just stood up and
boom and just beled me you know and it
was in front of the referee because in
professional stuff you wouldn't get that
yeah there's no way you'd get that
because you got cameras everywhere on
you and so he was just like n not having
in that W fully deserved that and then
penalty well you're off and he's like
what just for smacking an all that you
know and then yeah after the game after
the game comes up you know buys me a
beer he's like sorry my head to I said I
was R let you
do
yeah sort of you forget what it's like
yeah but um you know back in back in the
day playing as an 18-year-old playing
senior Club footy yeah that's you'd
expect that if that's what you did you
know there's no way you would have done
it but yeah you just sort of you forget
what it's
like oh that's so cool and then we
obviously heard about your transition
into the work life um but what are your
plans going forward like your kids are
starting to get a bit older have you
have you got an ambition to coach or um
yeah there's a there's a wee burning
desire there you know and having and
having this um this pilot thing with uh
Super Rugby this year has really put a
put a bit of fuel on it and um seeing
what could potentially come of it would
be it it would be awesome um being able
to look after the the younger ones
coming through and getting a a national
program like that established would be
awesome
andit
itate hookers through um that's that's
really cool obviously once the kids once
the kids um uh fly the C then having
that in the back pocket will allow a
little bit of travel and you know seeing
the wide world again um in terms of
coaching professionally I don't know you
know like I do I do love coaching but um
you know is seeing the amount of work
that the coach has put in is it's huge
you and then you don't get the ability
to go out and take your frustrations out
at the end of the week you know you just
got to sit there and hope like hope like
it works fingers
crossed um but yeah I mean I'm I'm
enjoying I'm
enjoying life outside of footy at the
moment in terms of um the ability to
put the time into the family everything
like that um but I think I'll have
another I'll have another itch you know
in a couple of years for sure but in the
in the meantime let this let this uh
throwing thing sort of take care of it
south and just keep pushing that yeah
and um obviously now that the boys will
finished the World Cup um talk to talk
to jaay once he's sort of decompressed
and and see see if that's uh a line that
he wants to take exciting times mate um
no doubt whatever you choose you'll be
very good at but we have gone to the
Instagram for some questions we've got a
few here I'm quickly try and race
through a few of these um most common
one was the story behind the tri
celebration the old um chicken wiar mate
people love that one eh yeah I still get
still get a few people ask for it now um
but a lot of a lot of people thought
that it was cuz I was allowed to eat KFC
or or something like that afterwards but
when we were kids well when we were
younger growing up
um one of my one of my groomsmen Kevin
Robinson when he got excited he would do
the chicken you know he would start
clucking like a chicken
and just anytime like yeah just when he
got excited and nine times out of 10 it
would be weing the lone St having beers
and in so um when he got really excited
he break into the seag and just go full
flat but um never really never really
got that into the tri celebration but
yeah so what it what it was was just I
knew that wherever the boys were in the
world um they trying to they' try and
watch the game yeah you know so if I if
I was able to score a try was just
basically saying get day of them you're
excited yeah
excited and saying good day and um yeah
so that was that's interesting the old
chicken one good good to hear the story
behind it okay next one best Cy
story um some of the ones that um you
know like you you think
about like back in the day say South one
when I was just a kid yeah we had met o
Connell and he was a he was a fairly
good scholar and um so he stood up and
he buff this jugg in something like 4
seconds
and I was like holy hell and then all of
a sudden because he had done it so well
the boys are like do it again he just
grabs another one he blows over another
jug and it's like Jesus and he did it so
quick it's like do it
again so he blows through three jugs and
then like the first one was or the last
one was as quick as the first one and
the boys were wanting more but he knew
that he was he knew that he was done no
no no
but you know and you think holy [__]
that stuff happened but then you know
like that's that's awesome as well but
then you've also got um you know you've
also got your team building stuff that
you have now in a which um which is
equally as good because it's different
times yeah you know and that's the thing
like um that one that we did for the
boys last year yeah true that's right
you know um having the having the myself
all come in and and then at the end when
we gave the levers the chance to talk
and you know how powerful it was right
never seen anything like it man there's
tears and I'm sitting there having to
show a m going Jesus and I'm you know
I'm wiping tears and I'm likeu and it
was it was pretty moving so that's the
sort of stuff that the court sessions
are really good for because they they
bring in so tight as a group that that
allows you to be be your true self I
suppose yeah so many different ways you
can take it like I'm
sure if you had one like that back in
your early Southland days it would have
been looked at a lot differently than
what it is these
days you end up on a FY
C okay um Nest player you played against
probably that heast Coast guy was
it uh Andrew [__] High yeah Hy was um
Hy good mate and we played a lot against
each other we we play Honda CTS um you
know stuff against each other back in
the day and then um then obviously
Crusaders hurricanes that sort of stuff
so yeah we we enjoyed it um and it was
great because we're good mates off it so
it always resulted in few bear the
banter and everything the nigle you knew
knew that it was just not it was just
that yeah so come the end of the game
you knew you going to be having a beer
and shaking hands yeah oh that's the
good stuff he yeah okay next one um keys
to being a good
leader um the ability to listen I think
now is um and and hearing and hearing
people's opinions
yeah um and that's a learn trait you
know learning learning that
through um through a lot of time would
be would be key you know I definitely
didn't have that at the start um but
yeah I think I think being a leader
you've definitely got to listen to to
the what's around you because if you've
got a good if you've got a good gauge on
what's coming in then you can you can
lead the way that you need to yeah I
like it okay two more tell the story of
when your wife punched you in the face
which
one uh so um actually she tells us
better than
me get her
on probably probably bigger lad than me
too but um uh so again close close to
the point of being at the bottom she had
had enough and I come home and I was
fairly fairly well
intoxicated anyway she was
she was like I'm going to knock this
prick out today you know and um
so she lined me up and I'm sort of
swaying and she gave it
everything if it's now it's now you know
this is going to be the time and she
reckoned she hit me that clean and flush
that I should have dropped but I just
stood up and like nothing had even
happened and that infuriated her more
cuz I didn't fall over she thought no
he's a stiff wind's just going to blow
this guy over yeah but yeah so she
whacked me full full noise and um yeah I
didn't couldn't do it I didn't tle so um
yeah so she was one didn't it didn't
sort of ease her mind she she was
Furious even more but um yeah got a
little bit of steam out of
her oh that's so good okay last one best
piece of advice you have for a wad
listener
um yeah I
suppose
listen
um
and listen listen to the older
guys um that are prepared to give you
the time if they if they're prepared to
give you the
time then
there's
um then you need to be able to listen to
take that knowledge yeah if you take
that knowledge then some Good's going to
come out of it um you know and because
in the end I got to where I got to and
I'm totally happy with where I got to
but I could have got there a way easier
way you know and um and coming to
Crusaders I had all of these guys
wanting to help like Mark hammmer um you
saw I saw the likes of uh Sammy white
loock on a Facebook post that he said
about me talking to young players and
I'm not going to give you the Jersey
yeah um but I'll give you everything
that I can for you to take the Jersey so
hammer did that to me you know I come
from in maago come from Southland and
Devon heaps he was told that I was going
to take a spot and for me to you know
for him to teach me everything yeah so
he took me away and he's like well
you'll learn how I [__] learn and
you'll get a hiding and you'll learn
from that yeah and then walked away I
was like okay that was me you know when
I come to the Crusaders Hammer comes up
and he said Den's told me that you're
going to take my spot um so what I'll do
is I need to make sure that you're going
to be ready and I'll give you everything
that I can any any knowledge I can part
with then I'll do it he said but you I'm
not going to give you the Jersey up to
you to take it so he gave that's that
was his teaching so I had Devon heaps
who's a champion don't get me wrong
absolute champion and then um and then
Mark Hammet so they were the they were
my two sort
of yeah what do I do here you but coming
from inago where you got a chip on your
shoulder I probably you know it wasn't
until I
was well down the track that I really
understood what Hammer was trying to
trying to give me you know and then when
your flip side when I gave that to the
likes of Ben forel Cody Taylor M Ben
finel was the Cory Flynn the young Cory
Flynn he just wanted me to he was like
[__] off your c yeah you know I'm I'm
better than you now yeah see you later
whereas Cody just staked it up he just
asked questions you know and um you know
and so and now talking to Benny he's
like GE I probably should have asked
more
questions so I suppose yeah that would
be that would be my bit of advice be
listen and um because the old boys have
got knowledge you know that's something
that they've always got and if they're
happy to give it soak it up yeah that's
so cool cuz I also remember talking to
Cody on the podcast around that sort of
coming into the environment learning of
you and obviously SP spoke so highly of
um everything he learned off you as well
so it's cool to hear both sides of that
Circle and it's cool for guys in those
positions cuz you you see it and you
know it when you're there you're getting
older and you see the young kid who's
awesome and you're like I don't know how
much long I've got but like you said
it's so important not to just pass it on
to him to make him really fight for it
and yeah mate and there was and like
having having the likes of T Pao Tony
kopalani those guys um coming through
Quinton McDonald and then you see all
those guys off and um you're like oh you
know then the ones that you see that you
know oh [__] I'm not going to get rid of
these guys yeah you know when Cody come
in and he's out there running like a
center stepping and it's like holy [__]
who is this
kid so you know um seeing those guys
that you know are going to surpass you
it's easier to accept yeah and then it's
like right well I've had a pretty good
run yeah I know the Jersey not forever
yeah let's just you know let's just put
it in good good Ste yeah mate what a way
to finish one of the great podcasts um I
knew it was going to be um been looking
forward to this one for a while but
awesome to um get you on and sit down
with you and hear from a true legend of
especially this region and New Zealand
and I'm a true lad appreciate you giving
up your time mate too easy mate it's uh
yeah like I said long time listener and
um really really enjoy what you're do
appreciate it you're l